meine familie meine familie hallo ich
heiße felix hallo ich heiße felix ich
bin 15 jahre alt ich bin 15 jahre alt
ich spiele fußball
ich habe zwei geschwister
einen bruder und eine schwester
das ist meine schwester lina das ist
meine schwester lina meine schwester mag
bücher meine schwester mag bücher
das ist mein bruder
denn das ist mein bruder mein bruder
marc ballett mein bruder marc ballett
das sind meine eltern das sind meine
eltern
rudolf das ist mein vater rudolf
mein vater mag hunde mein vater mag
hunde
das ist meine mutter hannelore das ist
meine mutter hannelore
meine mutter mag schnee
das sind meine großeltern
das ist mein großvater uli das ist mein
großvater uli mein großvater mag sport
mein großvater mag sport das ist meine
großmutter hermine das ist meine
großmutter hermine meine großmutter mag
fleisch meine großmutter mag fleisch
das ist mein onkel leo das ist mein
onkel leo
mein onkel mag musik mein onkel mag
musik
das ist meine tante mia
meine tante mag yoga meine tante mag
yoga
das ist mein cousin samuel das ist mein
cousin samuel
[Musik]
mein cousin mag feuer mein cousin mag
feuer
mein bruder ben ist verheiratet mit
paula mein bruder ben ist verheiratet
mit paula
das ist meine schwägerin paula das ist
meine schwägerin paula
meine schwägerin mag meine schwägerin
marc schuh
ben und paula haben zwei kinder
denn und paula haben zwei kinder
das ist mein neffe dann das ist mein
neffe denn das ist meine nichte lily das
ist meine nichte lily das ist meine
familie
okay ich habe zwei kinder
ich habe zwei kinder
meine tochter heißt mir meine tochter
heißt mia
[Musik]
mein sohn heißt just in mein sohn heißt
justin
[Musik]
das ist also meine familie
die mutter
der vater der vater
der bruder der bruder die schwester die
schwester
die großmutter die großmutter
der großvater der großvater onkel der
onkel
die tante die tante der cousin der
cousin
die schwägerin die schwägerin der neffe
der neffe
die nichte die nichte
die tochter die tochter
der sohn der sohn
[Musik]
familienquiz
wer ist meine tante wir ist meine tante
genau das ist meine tante mia
was mag meine großmutter was mag meine
großmutter ich mag fleisch ich mag
fleisch
wie heißt mein vater wie heißt mein
vater
ich heiße rudolph ich heiße rudolph
was mag wohl mein cousin
[Musik]
www.hhl.de schule punkt ch na hast du
mut dann drücke hier
möchtest du weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere und liken dankeschön
[Musik]